I draw his entire show it was just one
big long-running audition for stripes -
can someone bring up a picture of Rin
Tin sorry Rin did not Rin Tin Tin Tin
Tin I was able to bring up a picture
attention let's listen to him let's hear
what kind of crazy crap he has to say
and you and I we have to believe in the
process and what we're told and we don't
credibility is key you have all right
okay Chris Cuomo let me tell you
something there's one thing they have a
differing opinion all right little Chris
little Chrissy or is that your wife your
wife is Christina I don't know she's
piggybacking off of your fame to sell
people crystal lamps how many how many
lives does she have on her hands by the
way Chris Cuomo but Chris Cuomo do you
know what the problem is here it's not
that you have a differing opinion you
don't think that Donald Trump has been
100% effective I think that all of us
here would agree that Donald Trump has
made some some good decisions and he's
made some missteps yes for example when
he tweeted out his craft about Sweden
today pissed me off but Anderson I
understand why he's doing it Donald
Trump I don't think I don't think
believes for a second I don't think any
mathematician or any epidemiologist
believes for a second that now knowing
what we know now and we had an absence
of data now we have overwhelming data
that 2.2 million American lives would be
lost okay but he wants to play that up
President Donald Trump because he wants
to say hey look this administration
saved two million lives so no Americans
are getting the truth from either at the
left who want to attack Donald Trump or
Donald Trump who wants to use their
standards by which to defend themselves
so I have a problem with Donald Trump
doing that that being said I think it's
understandable but Chris Cuomo you may
have a differing opinion from Donald
Trump and I understand that reporter
should hold the president accountable my
main gripe with you Chris Cuomo is why
do you not ever hold the Chinese
communist government as accountable as
you hold Donald Trump no not all
accusations that can be levied against
the Chinese government can be aimed at
the United States not at all like the
whistleblowers disappearing like lying
about a virus like blaming it on
American troops no they can't there is
not any kind of an a moral equivalency
between the two I
just wish that Chris Cuomo you were as
outraged about the Chinese government
silencing and likely killing its own
journalists as you are about Donald
Trump now being pissed off at the
Chinese government for silencing its
journalists or you know what at the very
least how about this be just be half as
pissed off at the Chinese propaganda
system as government as you are at
people riding bicycles while you're
lying about yourself quarantine you
stupid show a weak prick come at me bro
you threatened to kick everybody's ass
me first I'm first in line and you name
the spot name the place it can be a
debate it can be a physical fight I know
you love to I know you love to challenge
people on that front on a regular basis
I've never issued this to anyone but you
you are a horrible dishonest disgrace
for a human being and I know I'm son in
Young Turks right now it just it should
at one point in this country we talked
about the polarization in this country
listen I get it there's right there's
left I understand it I know the promis'd
polarization for example when it comes
to abortion up until including nine
months right I think some partisanship
is pretty good you know we're there you
know where we should be united we should
be united when a foreign government lied
about a virus that you covered by the
way you actually covered their their
tweets and their quote saying that it's
going to be transmitted from human human
contact just disappearing magically
they're journalists silencing dissent
committing gross abuses of human rights
especially when they are against your
country you are a communist sympathizer
and you hate the United States of
America and you know what this is more
legitimate journalism than your show
because you're talking to Donald Trump
who you know doesn't watch your show
like everyone else in America but I know
that your network has someone watching
this stream because you took down your
oopsie mistake of including an Aryan
Brotherhood retweet if you enjoyed this
video you can subscribe or hit the
notification bell and one of these
buttons or watch another video but you
know this this thing is you don't um I
mean you don't you don't have to
I'm a dive I'd like it if you did you
know I'm a lot of effort and do it
whatever you want